have you ever thought what happens if a
species went extinct now if a species
goes extent it's taken out of the food
chain some of you might not think that's
that big of a deal but let me give you
an example of what happened back in the
day in 1930 wolves were driven near to
Extinction in Yellowstone Park in the
U.S and what happened as a result of
that the number of elk and tear
multiplied and the overgrazed on Aspen
Willow and Cottonwood plants and these
plants were a habitat for songbirds and
beavers now because of the reduction in
songbirds what happened was that insects
like mosquitoes multiplied drastically
and the stream Banks due to
deforestation were left vulnerable to
erosion now in 1995 when wolves were
reproduced things went back to normal
what can we learn from this guys nature
evolve the weight has for a reason and
we should not interfere and in fact
strive to conserve all species right
comment down below what you have learned
And subscribe to don't memory